with the success of the lower the Rings
it only made sense that Disney Sora
wanted to do their own version but
because they couldn't get Toki and they
decided to go to his bestfriend CS Lewis
and since Disney is more kid oriented
and made more sense to go to a story
that was also a bit more kid oriented
enter The Chronicles of Narnia The Lion
the Witch and the Wardrobe I have to
admit when I heard they were making a
movie on this I did get a little nervous
as I knew the story and I didn't know if
audiences will connect with it it is
when you get down to it really strange
and really bizarre but they found a
really good mix updating the effects and
tone while still keeping true to the
book spirit thank Bedknobs and
Broomsticks meets the two towers it
starts off in wartime and four children
have to be separated from their mother
they're sent to live with a professor
who has an enchanted wardrobe and when
you walk inside you enter into a
fictional realm called Narnia but Narnia
is currently being ruled by an evil
sorceress known as the White Queen but
as the kids journey into the land and
find out more about it they discover
that they're actually fulfilling a
prophecy that they would be the heroes
to lead her into room and that they
would result in the return of a slime a
giant heroic lion who will bring light
back to the good land of Narnia colorful
characters are met destinies are
discovered and battles are fought to
decide who will rule the enchanted
kingdom I was really impressed with how
well they were taking sort of these
silly images and elements and actually
making them very serious two of the best
friends in this are talking beavers and
I really thought oh man this is gonna
bomb when we get to that but it works
out really well the animation on them is
very good and they have very distinct
characteristics and personalities the
White Queen is a good villain and all
the child actors do a pretty good job
too and yes I know that looks like
Lindsey Ella's I've made a joke before
what really helps pull it through is the
heart that it has and there is a lot of
it in here the book itself is very vague
and a quick read but here they give a
lot of details to the characters
connection and relationships the best
one being with Lucy and mr. Thomson my
god I love watching these two together
that's James McAvoy who I'm convinced
can do absolutely no wrong well almost
the scenes these two have together just
not get out
part I almost wish it was just about
them but when the action has to come in
and the story has to get a lot bigger it
does exactly that I'll warn you now
though that you thought some of the
religious symbolism in the Lord of the
Rings was a bit obvious this beats you
over the head with it there is no doubt
who these characters are what they're
representing it's in your face but I
didn't mind too much because it still
makes for a good story even if I didn't
know it was symbolic of I would still
really enjoy it
the only thing I couldn't get into was
the story arc with Peter he's supposed
to be the king the big ruler the guy
who's supposed to come into his own and
rule the kingdom and yeah he's just kind
of bland I had the same problem with
Aragorn in Return of the King he's
supposed to be the ruler the guy who's
supposed to be in charge of everything
and all you do is just see him chop up a
bunch of guys nothing much else I think
if they got that element down this would
be on par with some of the great epic
fantasies but as is it's still pretty
good it's probably one of the most
difficult adaptations you could do in
terms of making it serious and I think
it really pays off the child actors are
good the animation is really good the
effects are a lot of fun and when you
get to the end it does feel really big
I'm really impressed with it it's not an
easy story to adapt and I think they did
a damn good job is it for everyone no I
mean if you're looking for something has
a lot more detail and logic to it it is
really that kind of story but for just
pure straight a fantasy with a lot of
incredible creatures and visuals this
one's definitely worth the trip